I want to start out today by just saying
a few words relating to the question of
inevitability which was the the question
asked from the midterm examination
whether the rise of the West was
inevitable and if so from what point the
the first point I make is that the
question assumes that the West exists as
a as an entity during most of the time
period that was suggested that is say
period from 1500 down to 1900 you would
have had a very difficult time finding
anyone who knew what the West was they
would have thought
Frances on their eyes or Britain is on
the rise or Spain is on the rise but
they wouldn't have a grenaded all the
things they these things together
particularly including North America as
the West this may not seem entirely
logical because we have been taught now
to recognize that the Orient is the
other of the West but in some respects
the Orient was created before the West
existed which is a could be a problem if
anybody wanted to pursue it very far in
other words we had an orient that was
thought of as being other than something
but it was more normally thought as
being other than say the Christian world
or other than Europe or other than a
particular country but the notion of the
West as a broad category the closest
thing you would get to it would be a
concept like Christendom and yet if you
posed the question was the rise of
Christendom inevitable after 1500 well
probably that would be a very difficult
question for anybody to to undertake
because we've now taken West to be to be
a a real entity and in some respects
this is a presumption that is at the
very root of the contemporary history
teaching of world history because the
first really influential book on world
history was William McNeil's the rise of
the West and by the time people were
reading that book and were impressed by
the book
the West had come into being and
interestingly the East by that time was
not the Orient
it was the Communist Empire so that the
rise of the West was not if you talk
about east-west politics in the 1960s
1970s 1980s you're not talking about the
West versus the Orient you're talking
about Europe and about NATO against
against the Warsaw Pact so there are
real difficulties with the whole notion
of the inevitability of the rise of the
West because of the assumption it makes
about the word West even leaving aside
the question of what the world
inevitable means
okay that's the first observation I make
the second observation I would make is
that if I had asked the question is the
rise of China inevitable that would have
been I think a very difficult question
for people to address because there the
word inevitable would have a predictive
aspect to it so one of the things about
the rise of the West being inevitable is
that it is strictly retrospective say
okay we know what happened hence let us
evaluate in some fashion why it happened
and how it might have happened
differently but say with the rise of
China is it inevitable in terms of the
arguments made in the the book referred
to in the mid term that is to say are
there or have there been moments when
the rise of China could be derailed or
the baby strangled and its cradle I
think was the image that used to me the
quote well when it's something ongoing
you could say well yeah I mean supposing
during the Korean War the United States
had had followed the advice of General
MacArthur and used the atomic bomb
against the People's Republic of China
and there had been a nuclear war that
had devastated China would that have
presented China from rising in the
second half of the 21st century which
those who look at China now feel is kind
of the likelihood now if if Mao had been
assassinated in
now 1948 instead of leading the
Communist Party to power would the would
a nationalist party leading China in the
post-world War two ERA have come to the
same kind of path that China has come to
now and I think you can hypothesize
these things and quite easily say well
sure something could have happened and
hasn't it but it's may still one doesn't
know ongoing historical processes are
much more difficult to assess then than
ones that appear to have have passed but
that's always in appearance because the
historian is the one who is deciding
what it is to look at and there's there
always other optics that can be used
other ways of looking at what has gone
on in the in the period since World War
two we have given and probably for some
time will continue to give singular
prominence to the to the Cold War and
people who are old enough to have lived
through that period well think that it's
hard how could you not do that but the
question of whether the Cold War needs
to be at the center of things
particularly now that it's 20 years in
the past and indeed you might even say
30 years since it was winding down
before the final fall of the Soviet
Union from the dissolution of the Soviet
Union how long are we going to continue
to say that that is the the great story
of the post-war
era and this is a problem that you have
in historical structuring and I
mentioned this in part because when you
embark on the final examination the
first you to write the first 200 words
of a final chapter which will be post
1991 those 200 words can be and need
maybe should be a kind of philosophical
run-up to the year 1991 in which you can
say well this is the end of something
but you can also say that actually new
things began before that and are now I'm
now going to highlight those things that
are continuing the year 1991 happens to
be the year that the authors of the
earth and its people chose as a dividing
point but it's not a necessary turning
point and indeed we had a huge argument
among the authors about whether there
was any date prior to 1991 and
subsequent to 1945 that seemed to be a
watershed year and of course one of the
problems of 1991 is going to be 2001
which is fear of 9/11 and and the
question of whether that is a watershed
year so anyway these are our
constructions so the Cold War is in many
ways a kind of of construct certainly
had enormous political and intellectual
force behind it as it turned out it did
not lead to a nuclear war and the wars
that were fought in the context of the
Cold War never reached the scale that
had been anticipated you know in the
late 1940s
it reminds me in a way of one of the
great structural concepts of the 19th
century
Oh which was entertained by British
politicians and thinkers in which they
talked about protecting the route to
India and how India was so important to
the wealth of Great Britain that all
sorts of strategies should be resorted
to to protect the route to India
countries were conquered or peoples were
conquered protectorates were established
institutions were put in place not least
of which of course finally the
governmental takeover of rural in India
in the 19th century by the British
government and yet you look back now and
you say well was the route was route to
India ever threatened or was this
something imaginary or not imaginary at
least let's say exceptionally low
probability people go back and they say
well Napoleon invaded Egypt in 1798 and
hoped to conquer the Middle East and
then march overland and attack the
British in India well come on that's a
long long way and it's true that
Alexander the Great got to India
marching across that territory and
defeating everyone he came in contact
with but even when he got to India his
troops were so tired and exasperated and
so forth that they wouldn't let him go
any farther but Napoleon's threat to
India was taken seriously so you had to
to protect the route
because the French might might get there
or in what was called the great game the
Russians might cross Central Asia and
get there how would they do that they
would conquer the Muslim khanates of of
Central Asia then they would simply you
know trip trip trip across Afghanistan
and then confront the British in India
while tripping across Afghanistan is
really really really hard the likelihood
that anybody was going to invade British
India from the north or from the
northwest across Afghanistan in
retrospect seems preposterous the
Afghanistan is not easy and of course
when the Russians finally did invade
Afghanistan they got their clocks
cleaned and they had to withdraw and the
clockwork is being scrubbed at the
moment so but but it there was no
difficulty in imagining these things so
in imagining the Cold War the idea that
there was a Soviet Colossus that was
going to to conquer everything if they
were not stopped at every possible
opportunity was something of an illusion
underlying it was the was the concept of
nuclear war and the question still
continues to this day as to whether
nuclear war was ever very likely during
the Cold War I know that when we write a
history book such as the one we have
before us we think of the Cuban Missile
Crisis
as a per as a place where the world came
to the brink of nuclear war I doubt it
nuclear war was something that was so
suicidal given the scale of the
Arsenal's to the other side that I find
it literally unbelievable that you would
have had the political leadership of the
other side saying let's do it we create
a image of this dr. Strangelove of
course is the the classic American
statement of it with Slim Pickens riding
a bomb down you know if his cowboy hat
on but realistically nuclear war was was
unthinkable as Herman Kahn wrote his
book thinking about the unthinkable it
really was something that the people who
were most involved and most responsible
knew how unthinkable a nuclear war was
the general public was encouraged to to
be much more fearful it supported the
political myths on on both sides and
creating these these myths it can be
very valuable in other words the the
myth of protecting the route to India
gave gave Britain an empire not all
parts of it but some parts of it Britain
took over territories because you know
there was an off chance so there would
be a threat to the road India look of
how Britain established itself in the
Persian Gulf area for example the the
Cold War probably was necessary as a
myth in order to facilitate the
ascendancy of the United States not the
ascendancy of the Soviet Union
containment was a containment was a
grand strategy but in containment of
course assumes that that the other side
is is expanding well that that is
something that can be that can be
debated I mean one of the great debates
of the Cold War era was the debate over
whether the Communist Party of Vietnam
was a tool of of worldwide communist
expansion Ho Chi Minh was certainly an
agent of the of international communism
in his personal history but whether the
Vietnamese ever intended to be
subservient to Soviet leadership when
they finally won the war they actually
maintained a rather independent posture
of particularly falling into quarrels
with China and today the
no the old communist side that won the
war in Vietnam does not appear to - how
much residue of that oh that notion
because the question was you know if you
have containment platter as it was that
you're trying to contain if the British
are protecting the route to India who
they're protecting it from the
assumption was that the French or the
Russians or somebody else wanted to
attack India you can go back to the to
the Roman period and how the Roman
Empire grew and I've mentioned this
before that Rome grew by defending
itself because the wars that have fought
were Wars of of defense you had a type
of priests a petiole
or a facial how we want to pronounce it
and the you that genetic College of
these priests and they were the ones who
advised the Roman government on on
diplomacy and matters of war if if Rome
had a grievance with someone a the the
leader of the Vettii ollies who was had
the title of Potter Petraeus he he was
supposed to go to the border with the
offending state and shout across the
border the demands of the Romans then he
was supposed to physically cross the
border and the first man he came to who
was supposed to tell him what it was
that the Romans demanded - to resolve
the dispute penny was supposed to
proceed on to the forum of that place
and in the four of you is supposed to to
announce an ultimatum that either you
you satisfy the green
that we have or you risk a war then he
would return to Rome and there be a
passage of 33 days during those 33 days
the other side had a chance to to amend
it's bad behavior whatever the bad
behavior happened to be but in other
words there was no there's no state of
war existing it's just that the Romans
had decided they had some neighbor who
was threatening or who had behaved badly
after 33 days if the Roman government
decided for there be a war then the head
of the Vettii Allie's would go to the
frontier and he would take a javelin
with blood on its tip and throw it
across the frontier while yelling
potentially time's up and then he would
come back to Rome and then there would
be a war but interestingly the wars that
were fought in this way which was the
dominant form of Roman coin the war for
in the earliest period the wars were not
fought in the name of the of the God of
War it was not Mars who was the the the
God of War under whose aegis the Roman
armies would march forth
it was either Jupiter or Juno or some
other God because it wasn't a war it was
a defense that was blessed by the gods
and being blessed by the gods was
essential and I think about that and how
Rome and the model of defending itself
ended up with a larger and larger and
larger state just as British defendant
of the British defending the route to
India end up with a larger Empire and I
think of how the United States uses
United Nations as a Collegium of priests
to bless Wars
I mean you think about this and how for
the United States to to initiate a war
without our warlike action without the
blessing of the nine nations is very
very uncomfortable for Americans we want
to have right on our side and the right
in the post-world War two period has
been whatever the the International
colic tivity has been that is as
relatively light Nations Security
Council or the our NATO or the Coalition
of the Willing made up of many states
around the world but the idea that the
United States would go to war all by
itself is something that's unattractive
because then it doesn't appear to be
necessarily to be just it appears to be
capricious or elective or you know non
sanctioned by some sort of larger
concept why did the United States move
along this route after 1945 after World
War one what was striking was that the
United States became isolationist it had
sent troops to Europe had taken
substantial losses and had a President
Woodrow Wilson who'd involved himself as
an internationalist in the in the peace
process the United States as a country
at that point had large numbers of
citizens living abroad and concerning
themselves with the affairs of local
people in the capacity of missionaries
particularly in mountain western areas
like China or India or the Middle East
got him an empire and yet the country is
a whole step back and said no we don't
we don't want to be involved with the
world at the end of World War two the
u.s. decided we wanted to be involved
with the world had the United States
become powerfully opposed to Bolshevism
and communism at the end of World War
two well Russia of course have been our
ally during World War two and we had
shipped massive amounts of armaments to
Russia in order to support their war
against Germany where is that the end of
World War one the United States was
intensely anti-bolshevik the you know
hatred of Bolshevism fear of Bolshevism
was stronger at the end of World War one
then it was in many respects of the
under World War two I may have mentioned
before the a book by Upton Sinclair
called goose-step which is a portrayal
of American higher education in the
1920s and where he goes from one
university campus to another to talk
about what is the character of these
universities what is being taught so
forth and so on Upton Sinclair was a
socialist and what and what he found
across the country again and again and
again was that intellectuals faculty
members who supported Bolshevism or
socialism or who knew somebody who did
support Bolshevism or socialism or who
were suspected of having these
tendencies they lost their jobs because
there was such a intense fear of this of
this thing the Red Scare of that period
was was it was very powerful and yet it
did not stimulate the United States
trying to do anything about the new
the new Soviet state and in fact in the
1920s many American businesses you know
supported economic development in the
Soviet Union so but when you come to the
end of World War two and normally you
you write this narrative and you say
there was a refusal of the Soviets to
remove it to remove their troops from
northwestern Iran and this was a crisis
ultimately a crisis resolved by Iranian
diplomacy and the Soviets withdrew and
then you had the the Iron Curtain the
Soviet takeover of Eastern Europe the
idea that there might have been a an
American takeover or Western Europe
never gets into the picture it's it's
the Soviets are the ones who are who are
expanding and then you have the Korean
War and the Korean War in which Russia
was not involved directly becomes the
proof that that expanse of communism
must be fought in military terms it
didn't have to happen that way
when the Soviet Union obtained an atomic
bomb and then a hydrogen bomb it wasn't
necessary to assume that they intended
to use them there are there reasons to
build weapons that are not predicated
primarily on the presumption that they
will be used in some specific or
near-term situation if you look at say
the history of dreadnaughts of super
battleships that drew down huge
proportions of the of the military
budgets of Britain and France and
Germany and other countries Japan in the
early 20th century you find that
competition in and of itself can explain
a lot of armament without necessarily an
assumption that those arms have a
logical use or a you know even a strong
will to use them you take the German
high seas fleet during World War one
never never fought a battle because if
they were defeated that would be
terrible so it's better not to fight
because of Fleet and being is better
than a fleet at the bottom of the ocean
so they spent all the money on on these
super dreadknots that never never fired
a shot during the course of the war so
we look back and we and we say well if
the Soviet Union has gotten the bomb and
let's assume that there were spies that
help them get the bomb well so there
were spies and they helped them get them
out now they have the bomb what exactly
were they going to do with the bomb
was there an intent to to obliterate the
United States a nuclear war or was this
a defensive position taken by the Soviet
Union in view of its own staggering
losses during World War two now you can
argue the American side of this or you
can argue the Soviet side of this and
not come to a to a fixed conclusion
because there's no way of proving that
these weapons never would have been used
but when you can you you construct all
this in the abstract you saw it as a
bipolar world with one great power
facing another great power and with a
somewhat weak effort by you know
non-western non eastern powers to create
a third world presence or a third world
alliance
one of the reasons I'm mentioning this
is because we're currently going through
an interesting period where India has
become a nuclear power
Pakistan has become a nuclear power
Iran may become a nuclear power
Israel is assumed to be a nuclear power
and there is a question as to whether
these things intrinsically mean that we
are near a nuclear war now when it was
us in the Soviet Union both sides were
convinced that nuclear war could could
happen by accident you know because of
what happened in Cuba or how it happened
in Berlin or what would happen in Turkey
or something like that now if you asked
people what do you think is the
probability of a nuclear war between
Pakistan and China Oh Pakistan and India
over the next 50 years I think you would
find a very different appraisal of the
significance of those nuclear weapons
then if you ask that question of what
was the probability of a nuclear war
between the Soviet United States you
know in the 1960 or 1970s there is a
question of what is the probability of a
nuclear war between Iran and Israel that
is of course the most pressing issue in
some circles at the present time there
are people who believe that unless there
are pre-emptive measures taken that it
is inevitable that Iran will initiate a
nuclear war against Israel and therefore
it is essential that those pre-emptive
measures be taken either by Israel
unilaterally or the United States
unilaterally are with Israel or by the
international community more broadly
that's one school of thought none of
those who will thought that maintains
that the likelihood of Iran initiating a
war against Israel hovers so close to
zero as to be a matter of of no
consequence in international affairs
first of all because Iran doesn't have
any nuclear weapons second of all
because Israel has lots of Devere
weapons and could respond to an attack
from by Iran in a devastating fashion a
with or without American help thirdly
because the rationale for such a war is
let's say sketchy at best it's pointed
out again and again that the president
of Iran has declared that at some point
Israel should disappear or will
disappear from the map and that the
Holocaust did not occur in the way that
Israel and her friends claimed and his
words are taken to be the sign of of a
let's say Holocaust intent
people who maintain this argument are
inclined to think that whatever the
President of Iran says must be the
position of Iran even though in
virtually every other juncture it is
observed that the president of Iran is
not a free agent and is under the aegis
of a supreme guide who has not said the
things of the President of Iran assent
and in fact has said Iran will never
acquire a nuclear weapon so we don't
know who has the authority to do what
but part of the problem here is that
there is an assumption that is made by
some people that the concept of mouton
of mutually assured destruction which
was the philosophy that gained power
during the Cold War as a way of
summarizing the nuclear balance and
nuclear standoff or the nuclear
stalemate between the Soviet Union
United States in order to to think about
an Iranian attack on Israel one has to
assume that the concept of mutually
assured destruction no longer has any
meaning and that mutual mutual neutral
two sides that the the assumption has to
be a lie student meaning that the
Iranians are willing to commit suicide
and see their entire country destroyed
simply in order to launch a weapon
against Israel that might or might or
might not work now I'm interesting ly
throughout the entire history of the
Cold War the idea that nuclear war would
come about because of of suicidal
insanity on the part of of one side or
the other
was discounted people said no it is so
awful so unspeakable that it's
impossible to imagine a head of
government initiating a nuclear war that
is going to result in the total
devastation of of his own country but
you know in the current debate that
assumption is being set aside on the
assumption on the grounds that Iran is
not a normal country it is a country of
jew-hating fanatics who will all go to
paradise
happily if there is the possibility of
destroying Israel this is a in the eyes
of some people this is a fantasy in the
eyes of other people this is a certainty
but it's what interests me in this is
that what we assumed throughout the Cold
War was that rationality was ultimately
related to what was going on even though
the the preposterous levels of overkill
that the two sides achieved were so
enormous that the risk wasn't of losing
a war and having your state devastated
but rather having the whole planet
devastated I sort of you know you know
game over search of scenarios and now
all of that logic is being sort of set
aside by in some quarters in order to
produce a different logic which is that
a fanaticism of sufficient intensity
will overrule all logic
well
to me this seems to be a an effort to
extend the intellectual construct the
myth of the Cold War into the post-war
Cold War period to create a concept of
of nuclear holocaust and nuclear
standoff
that's ideologically driven that will be
a continuation and that the of what we
had in the Cold War and that essentially
it's an effort to create a power in the
world or to assert that there is a power
in the world that is substituting for
the old communist menace of the of the
you know we had before the 1990s
what is the value of having the world
conceived of in terms of a violent
bipolarity some people would argue that
bipolarity having you know maximum
threats of one side against another you
know Israel in America in this case
against Iran and a billion fanatic
Muslims around the world that the value
of this is that it is a powerful
structuring concept for economics for
strategy for military procurement for a
placement of military assets etc etc and
that in the absence of a bipolar world
you get potential chaos because every
country will have its own interest
instead of having the American interest
versus you know whoever the adversary is
so what we had what we found in the
1990s was that you had many people who
were trying to create an alternative to
the Soviet Union as the enemy of the
United States and as time has gone on
that alternative has has fluctuated some
but it's primarily either the Muslim
world or more in a more far-fetched
fashion China it's interesting you know
China has a huge arsenal America is a
huge arsenal China is competing for
dominance in the world's economic sphere
the United States and competing for
dominance world economic sphere China is
developing relations with countries and
Central Asia Africa you know acquiring
raw materials United States
you know acquires raw materials abroad
develops and yet nobody is saying that
there's a cold war between China in the
United States
it's not quite clear why instead we are
focused on the on Iran which is a
frankly a pretty weak and chaotic and
hopeless state now more dangerous well
that's what big guys say about little
guys all the time now I think part of it
is that at the end of World War two
Americans and Western thinkers as a
whole began to think in global terms in
a way that they never had before when
you look at the big thinkers of the 19th
century or the 18th century or the 18th
century you you you you can see some
inputs from abroad in terms of oh you
know
c'est Montes kills Persian letters or
something like that but by the 19th
century the big thinkers in Europe
thought of the non-european world as a
area of imperial expansion and their
their thoughts were primarily about
themselves and about how they had
developed how they were developing how
great they're gonna go so forth and so
on
you know Marx wrote about Europe and
then created something called the
oriental mode of production in order to
explain the rest of the world that's the
world becoming sort of a residual
category once you had talked about the
really interesting stuff which was
European what happens
after World War two is that people in
the West in particular begin to think
that they have to understand the entire
world and to act in the entire world
they also became convinced or convinced
themselves that they could understand
the entire world I look back and I I
think this is really very peculiar the
knowledge about areas outside of Europe
and North America that was accessible to
policymakers and intellectuals in the in
the 1950s 1960s was extremely thin
we knew very little about China very
little about India very little about
Middle East a little bit more about
Latin America virtually nothing about
Africa and yet American intellectuals in
academia in the 50s and 60s pride in
themselves in coming up with theories
that explain the entire world and they
would usually ground those theories by
going back and seeing what people
thought about in the 19th century in the
18th century say well let's start with
Thomas Hobbes and where does that get us
because after all Thomas Hobbes must
have understood the entire world when he
said that that primal man lived in the
state of the war of all of all against
all know what why would we think that
Hobbes would know that why would we
think that Adam Smith understood the
nature of economic phenomena
categorically but everyone can look back
and see limitations on these earlier
thinkers but they provide the sort of
bedrock ideas that then in the
post-world War two period turn into
bedrock ideas for for thinking of of the
world as a whole in the post-world War
two period as I say this was
particularly an American phenomenon and
it was institutionalized in the form of
area studies in which we expected
Americans to study foreign areas for Oh
two or three years and then grasp the
total nature of the society
ah
this couldn't be done no I tried it and
this is what my whole career was bent on
doing I was supposed to study the Middle
East and I had the advantage of starting
my sophomore year in college and I got a
BA to two-thirds of all my college
courses dealt with the Middle East and
then two years of graduate school and I
had a master's degree in Middle East
Studies in three more years I have PhD
in history and Middle East Studies and
what I knew about the Middle East really
wasn't very much it was really pretty
thin gruel but it was awful lot better
than the people who had just gotten that
two-year MA who were then going into
government to becoming ambassadors and
you know planning on Wars and things
like that it wasn't very much partly
because there wasn't much available to
to learn a bit from now in 1960 it was
possible to read everything that came
out in English dealing with Islam and
the Middle East on a regular basis it
read everything no another month there
are three more issues of this journal in
that journal you can go through read the
articles and you can catch up on
everything
you had one encyclopedia the
Encyclopaedia of Islam you could read it
it was still coming out and I would get
my fascicle encyclopedia of Islam and I
would know read through it so you could
end up getting vast amounts of
information but it was information about
30 countries
you know half a dozen language areas you
know 2,000 years of time it was just you
know
incomprehensible how anyone would expect
you to have real knowledge but the
people who were producing the big ideas
of that period knew far less than I did
because they were they were assuming
that they had a unique capacity to
understand everything that was happening
in the world this is I refer to it in
the last lecture as as hubris and it
truly was the I do not disparage the
people came up with big ideas at that
time because at the level of generality
of which we were trying to learn things
about foreign areas it was very
important to have big structuring wrong
ideas or big structuring ideas all of
which proved to be wrong because you
needed something to hold things together
like you had to think Arabs are X
Chinese are Y Indians come in two
flavors Muslims and Hindus Africans LS
they even talk about them so you had
general works by sociologists and
political scientists by historians by
anthropologists that were explaining the
entire world
nothing like that occurred after World
War one the u.s. had no interest in the
entire world after World War two
suddenly the entire world was a matter
of intense interest and we would try to
institutionalize the study of it so that
we could understand it it's just that
the basis for that understanding was so
weak that the understanding almost by
definition had to be wrong and and it
was
profound oversights and mistakes and so
forth in the area that I'm most
concerned about it was very striking
that between the end of World War two
and the Iranian Revolution of 1979 there
were only three books written by
American academics dealing with Islam in
the contemporary world there were lots
of books dealing with Muhammad and
medieval Islam but nobody was writing
about contemporary Islam one ex-cia
person wrote a book on the Muslim
Brotherhood in Egypt another person
wrote on the Muslim Brotherhood in Egypt
and a third person wrote about Egypt but
outside of Egypt nobody is writing about
Islam the reason was that we had a huge
idea saying that traditional society
which is which in gloss saying
religiously oriented society is obsolete
and will pass away or become entirely
privatized in an emotional and
intellectual sense and therefore
religion is of no importance of course
this is an extension of the 19th century
thinking about about Christianity in
Europe or about Judaism among people who
were who were left the Orthodox outlook
behind the assumption was that the world
will evolve going forward in the way
that Europe has evolved up to that point
that
just as Europe becomes post-christian
the rest of the world will become post
him to post Buddhist post Muslim post
everything because religion no longer
counts for for anything leave aside the
previous several thousand years because
it's now been all changed religion
wasn't supposed to count for anything
and therefore we weren't supposed to
know anything about it because I don't
need to know anything about it so we
have we're in this ironic situation
where we were training people to go to
to the Islamic world and study economic
and political development or tribal
structure or urban no urban development
natural resource management so on and we
didn't have any young scholar who went
off and asked of the people who were in
his own age cohort in these Muslim
countries what they were reading so you
had a a potent you know neo Muslim
ideologue the most potent one in many
respects
seiyya Clinton who had who is writing
but in favor of revolution in favor of
violent activity by Muslims against the
West and who had been to the United
States and spent time in the United
States and had an excavating critique
right or wrong of the United States and
that was the book that was having a huge
impact on young people and our students
who were of the same age cohort as those
who were reading say it could have never
asked what they were reading and never
read say Akutan because we had simply
declared that religion categorically was
no longer important so we ended up
knowing nothing about the one area that
in 1979 with revolution Iran becomes the
key area
for your generation that meaningful you
know for us we read and where do you
start in 1979 so you're right it's when
we debated where to break the chapters
and we we agree in 1991 and probably
because we were all kind of oldest and
we couldn't agree on any date before
that then the debate we suggested was
1968 the youth rebellions that you had
in different parts of the world 1979 was
something we discussed but then we
thought it was too parochial because it
dealt with the Iranian Revolution and
Islamic Middle East the idea that we
would go from 79 down to say 2009 50
years later the Islamic presence would
now be seen as a global phenomenon and
that you would have a hysteria about it
building up comparable to the Red Scare
hysteria that you had against Bolshevism
earlier in the 20th century now that was
unimaginable in 1979 even when Islam
came to be a source of humiliation for
the United States as it did with the
hostage crisis in Iran even then that
was not ascribed to Islam that was
ascribed to those Shiite Iranians who
were not real Muslims real Muslims were
Sunni Muslims and Sunni Muslims were
peaceful people whereas those the
Shiites who were suicidal fanatics this
was said over and over and over and over
again that you know 90% of Muslims were
Sunnis and therefore peaceful and 10% or
Shiites and most of those were Iranians
and they are horrible fanatics
they are an enemy now we have
Islamophobia projecting the idea that
Islam as a religion is a religion of PDF
files and you know wifebeaters and no
gruesome sinners you know hand hackers
and so forth by definition so in a sense
but I'm suggest your is that over time
it's Lomb becomes a bigger and bigger
enemy not that there's a whole lot
changing but the conceptual
conceptualization of it grows bigger and
bigger whereas the conceptualization of
the of the communist menace grows bigger
and bigger from World War one on until
it becomes a vast world girdling
conspiracy in the in the Cold War period
which all makes me very apprehensive
about the future of relations between
America in the Muslim world but that's
for the future to to determine but what
I'm really interested in here is why did
American thinkers decide that they could
understand everything and I think it was
because they had defeated the Nazis you
know we had a world war and we won and
they lost and we won because we were
smarter or better etc etc and they felt
that everything now could be understood
particularly by those people who had
served in the spy service during the war
the organ the Office of Strategic
Services the OSS who became the the
founders of the CIA
and other intelligence agencies that
that made it crucial to to expand the
notion of American presence in the world
as a whole
one of the first CIA agents to be lost
was a scholar whose specialty was on on
medieval Islam his name was Daniel
Dennett he wrote a book that still is
considered a significant monograph
called
conversion in the poll tax and early
Islam and had a PhD in Islamic studies
and he be ended up in the CIA and was
lost over I believe Ethiopia on an
unauthorised mission and then his
mission compatriots back in Beirut had
to invent a story to cover up the fact
that he was there basically I think just
because he'd never been to Ethiopia and
he thought it'd be cool to go there but
there was a very strong element of
amateurish ness and Lee in the early
days of the CIA which has now been
overcome by a very strong feeling of
bureaucracy
why did the United States do this there
was no one else to do what to run the
world but the the idea that the world
had to be run is so is so bizarre now if
it really is in a sense the equivalent
of what Victorian Britain thought that
the world was run by England and all for
the best because nothing could be better
than Victorian England except in all of
the particular details that we now point
to as being horrible but but the idea
that somebody had to run the world is
you know it's anomalous it you know it
rarely occurs I think the Romans thought
somebody had to run the world there
certainly is a strong thread in Chinese
history the idea of the Middle Kingdom
that all the north and east and south
and west barbarians report and have
tributed relations to the to the Middle
Kingdom is a sort of running the world
phenomenon but it's not a necessity the
world actually is capable of running
without somebody at the helm and I think
this is one of the one of the issues
that were running into over the next or
the coming years the United States yes
does the United States need to run the
world or is it time to sit back and say
let the world run itself and develop
multiple polls instead of a bipolar
phenomenon so when you see the clash of
civilizations arguments and the Islamic
lobia and the efforts to say it's us
against them on the one hand then you
balance them against
visions that say well maybe the US
should have a more modest role in the
world and and not get so upset if you
have India and China and Brazil and who
knows where rising to share the eminence
that we we once had the problem with
this is that it it has just as the
British Empire was at its peak under
Queen Victoria when Britain loses the
Empire what do they have to substitute
for soccer hooliganism
you know the Falkland Islands war as
kind of the you know the the cartoon
short subject at the end of the show I
mean the the mental and intellectual
impact of stepping down from Empire is
very difficult to to assess but we can
see countries that have that have
suffered that you know role it's not
clear that Rome had to disappear that is
say Latin might have continued things
might have continued but it didn't we
still don't have a very clear notion of
exactly why Roman civilization
disappears or many other civilizations
but certainly the the sense of coming to
the end of something is not simply a
matter of describing a political or a
military and economic situation it's
also a matter of assessing the the
psychological emotional intellectual
impact of of stepping down from the helm
and
I started by talking about was it
inevitable that the West would rise well
what's the West obviously it means less
then the question of is inevitable that
that China will rise
well one final thought would go back to
Oswald Spengler 'he's the decline of the
West the winter gongju sahabat Landis
and the question is is it inevitable
that the West will decline and taking
the notion of counterfactual history is
there anything that could be done that
would prevent the West from declining
now if you answer a nuclear attack on
Iran I won't be happy but but you could
make that argument I suppose but
economic influence role a dollar you
know the role of the of the renminbi you
know which is the support for the dollar
it's it's a difficult argument to make
in any case the I have great doubts
about the long-term durability of the
Cold War as a structuring element in
history although as a great myth I think
it has it has legs on Tuesday I'm going
to devote my lecture to talking about
human animal relations this is a
I know you cannot bring your pet in this
is a area of intense interest for me in
which I think we are at the dawn of a
new era and I want to explain that
because I don't think I will ever teach
my course on history domestic animals
again and then on Thursday next week
which will be the last lecture I will
try and cobble together some general
thoughts about world history and how to
teach it